“This episode of DNews is brought to you
by Full Sail University.”
People ask ALL THE TIME why we're exploring
space and if that money could help people
on Earth.
I'm here to tell you IT ALREADY DOES HELP!
One of the biggest questions we get whenever
we do space stories is "why are we spending
all this money on space travel?
What does it do for me?"
And I'm here to tell you…
It does a crap-ton for you.
And I’m not just talking about stupid stuff
like batteries, eyeglasses, GPS navigation,
weather satellites or global telecommunications
-- because who needs THOSE things, amirite?
In 1962, NASA created a program of offices
specifically dedicated to track Technology
Utilization and Industry Applications of NASA
efforts.
Since 1976, they've published an issue of
what they call "Spinoff" every year, cataloging
nearly 1,800 projects.
The projects are commercial ventures using
tech either wholly developed by NASA, created
in partnership or by contract with NASA, or
using NASA patents, experience, technology,
research, personnel, data… et cetera.
Basically, if NASA wasn't around, many of
these techs probably wouldn't be either.
One that caught my eye from the 2013 issue
of Spinoff, was the Space Shuttle Main Engines,
inspiring new solar power plants.
It might not seem immediately obvious, but
it stuck with me.
An SSME would kick on in temperatures as low
as -423 F (217C) and burn as hot as 6,000
F (3316C) -- hotter than the boiling point
of iron.
It was built for NASA, but the company that
built it (now owned by Pratt & Whitney), took
the experience of working with superheated
materials and turned it into a 110-megawatt
solar plant which powers 75,000 homes in Nevada.
Sunlight is concentrated onto a single point
at the top of a tower, and superheated salt
is used to create steam and turn turbines.
They created a company called SolarReserve
which is now opening plants all over!
If you're feeling distracted, another NASA
spinoff might help.
Unique Logic created a game that helps you
learn to pay attention by monitoring your
brainwaves!
See, NASA scientists know that too much automation
makes the mind wander, and they wanted pilots
to have an automated system that could tell
if they were distracted..
If a pilot wandered too far off task, the
flight simulator would release more controls
to manual -- forcing them to focus.
Whereas if they were on task, the sim would
take over more controls.
This was in the 1980s!
Today, the technology has been adapted for
video gaming, the nuclear power industry,
US Olympic sports, and NASCAR!
Speaking of sporting events, another spinoff
is the GigaPan.
You've probably seen these online; they're
giant images taken from mountaintops or building
spires, or at events which let you zoom in
a seemingly IMPOSSIBLE amount to see shoes,
read newspapers or find faces in a crowded
stadium.
The technology was originally developed for
use on the Mars rovers Spirit and Opportunity.
It showed up in Spinoff in 2008, when Gigapan
began marketing the technology to consumers
and event planners.
It works by taking hundreds of photos, and
then stitching them together using software.
It creates a very compact system (perfect
for space travel) and creates GIANT images
(great for analyzing an alien planet).
And that's just THREE of these amazing technologies!
Software designed to test the control of spacecraft
long before takeoff has inspired bank fraud
protection.
And software for analyzing satellite images
of stars was pointed at the human brain to
help detect alzheimer's in MRI scans.
The number of technologies touched by manned
exploration of space is incredible.
So next time someone writes, "What a waste!"
in the comments, link them to this video.
Oh, and point out that Tang isn't a thing.
It was invented for use on the ground.
Sure, NASA tried it out but it's not a thing.
Let's move past that myth.
What's your favorite space technology?
I think mine might be LED lights that help
plants grow.
More food for everyone!
Tell us yours down below!
None of these techs would be possible without
software to run the system, and we need people
to write that software!
Full Sail University in Florida offers courses
to help train tech professionals by blending
code and real-world experience.
Students of Full Sail have hands-on access
to technology on their first day, they get
a discounted laptop and all the software they'll
need to earn degrees in software, mobile and
web development.
They offer a blend of coding AND real-world
experience.
Which is the best way to learn.
To find out more and support our show go to
fullsail.edu/dnews!
Thanks for watching!